much of Harry Potter's cast was very
young when they started filming the
franchise and of course they spent a
huge chunk of their adolescence bringing
these characters to life Bonnie Wright
was only 9 years old when she first
stepped into Jenny Weasley's shoes and
by the time she finished she was 19 yes
I was nine and then I went yeah for in
total just two auditions it's clear that
Wright nailed her surprisingly quick
audition process despite the fact that
she didn't imagine that she'd end up
being chosen as Jenny from 9 to 19 years
old as I was in the series like that's a
massive period of your life where like a
lot is going on still Wright was happy
that she was able to live a relatively
normal life during what she refers to as
her awkward teenage years there were
certainly some unique challenges when it
came to starting out so young in such a
massive franchise it's been definitely
jumping in at the deep end so it's been
a quick learning process but I think
everyone who works on these films is so
passionate